welcome to this video playing ha 98 from
this Lebanon yeah yeah talk about a
wacky combination we have a German name
with a lack of the Lebanon okay yeah
this is some really wacky line of the
drop-off scheme that recently in fact
got recommended and brian is the droid
should put only kind of spot in the rich
richer put an English or British I think
he's English on international master in
this book on the [ __ ] offski well
complicated stuff um what to do now just
terribly d 6 p-6 a very Cecilia type of
position there should be six books yet
maybe not sure how to how to develop my
Kings side hmm can play age 60 me 40
will he will probably take anyway okay
maybe I can first um mobilize the Queen
side like that maybe something about 95
threatening looks III
one night pppp for even before e3 rocks
it for you
yeah still my bishop on David is not
playing at all 95 he might even play
Bishop to b5 my paternal bishop this am
NOT not a big deal yeah of course I
would love to get this the sacrifice in
but what about okay age 6 okay then
thinking that maybe Bishop g7 and f5 is
an option in this position
the bishop on g7 would be simply simply
great hmm we should g7
don't really see how it prevents it but
i can't play Bishop d3 m-maybe this one
yeah but thank you should do something
against at five if I just template a
five without being hmm ok so if I go at
five where how does he punish me Queen
Queen g3 or maybe or i don't i don't see
it at the moment now Queenie seven
design something I must must be careful
not move the night in this queen is
having made after five yeah this must be
the right move activating my my bishop
on g7 this should be correct I'm not
sure though what my response to 23 years
maybe I can just take will be to Queen a
bishop be to King be too and then fe 4
and 2 nights are hanging yeah really
stretch line but maybe that's working
could be
yeah here's one one one case where 95 is
looking like nice move and it's a
answered by Queenie subject made so this
is one of those cases where some
coercion is required okay let's see I
take we take not great but what is
happening
I was thinking about coming a form you
have this media is really a really a
problem okay don't play with I mean I'm
thought I'm thinking far too long him
maybe I should know if I castle he can
yeah should be three but Bishop to
Bishop d3 is no threat not not a real
threat at least I can't just move the
rock besides others probably but how do
I actually continue yeah I didn't didn't
think it's such a big issue here holding
it's just a check underneath I hope
night eh no not a tribe is not possible
the queen is covering that
mmm very tricky position I just want to
have a threat as well not sure but if
it's a dangerous but I want a threat as
well Quincy 3 now check if we trade
Queens I'm I'm really I'm really
satisfied check g4 if I have aged 5 I
could take it check check
yet so it's a rather compact position
from black not not any big problem
time morning check no check yeah not any
big problem yeah this was right eotech
just idiotic this is how your of course
you can lose the position blood sharing
blundering big material check check
check check check check check check your
check I lose on time every time let's
see maybe I can black for fake Santa no
I lost but I did it got really close it
got really close ah ok what the heck the
King fa they are very stupid yeah I just
just spent far too much time before that
check yeah yeah this should be at least
that it's a playable position and not a
rope down he needs to play g 6 cm yeah
very very tricky
yeah maybe six or something it should be
about equal here don't think there's
something something going on but if you
blunder oh look who you're going to
deuce ah alright but is it is what about
this i mean around here isn't let me let
me just just check around here i'd like
to like to see a bit of analysis here
you have the computer gives wider a very
substantial edge with moves like Bishop
c4 change then I know Bishop c4 yeah
that's that's an interesting move of
course very interesting threatening
night g6 and Quincy ate meat yeah yeah
interplay 6cm that's similar to the game
but in d6 is saying at the end yeah my
king position was so I was too shaky
here it should be ok but I am well I
blonde at the rook what can you do
alright thanks for watching